you could try to bring the Rook he's
going for it going for the attack y he's
all in right he's all in yeah before you
uh go for it this might be a little bit
slow but you know we're going to see it
will he capture that pawn on that hook
on H6 now will he go for it mating Paton
to remember Bishop check he's played it
w the Knight cannot be touched it's
poisoned but how do you defend a crazy
position like this perfectly with 3
minutes yeah maybe Magnus can do it I
mean we've seen him play the best moves
several times already he's got he's
played the best move of course I mean
how' you beat this guy if he just plays
the best move every time it's he's well
Champion siron I know no matter where
the White Queen goes now the White Queen
attacked by the Black Knight then black
will capture this white knight and a
quick material count shows that black
has a bishop and a knight for one of the
white Rooks a few moments later the
second draw of the final but l a
dramatic draw it's been I bet you they
both shake their head right both like oh
no